one on the outside two touch well played
that's beautiful
nice thinking about that weight of pass
and some great body positions
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
hi i'm gareth southgate and i'm here
with the guys from sport bible
to meet the rising ballers i'm really
looking forward to getting into the
session with them
and also talking to them about what it
takes to be a top pro
[Music]
[Applause]
all right listen boys very very tough
decision for myself
something i'm not taking very lightly my
two years at rise and borders
unfortunately it's going to have to come
to an end you know i've been amazing
we've got a new interim manager all
right he's going to be walking in
just about now all
how are you right i know what you're
going to say you'd rather keep the old
one
no problem no problem i can see why so
guys we're just going to do about an
hour
we're going to do some little drills
build up towards the game so you can
show me everything that you've got
before the end of the night hopefully
you're going to enjoy yourselves and
we'll have a bit of fun
basically one on the outside two touch
just start playing
and we'll go from there okay that's it
that's it
that's it
nice good nice
good so thinking about that weight of
pass and what you've started to do
really well is is draw them in
yeah draw them in so you've got the time
we can keep it between us we can keep it
between us
then when they come bump bump out of the
pressure
yeah and some great body positions
okay well played that's beautiful
yeah well played yeah very good
very good they can player so the way the
game's going more and more
is teams when they lose the ball
straight away quick pressing
yeah you're seeing that who what would
be a good example of a team that pressed
really
quickly and well yeah yeah absolutely
liverpool by munich so as soon as teams
are losing the ball they're reacting
really quickly
switching from being defending to
attacking that transition moment
having a having a picture quick passes
out then actually you find a bit of
space
but so many teams now win the ball back
so quickly that to find those first two
passes is really key
so that little session helps you to to
switch into that
we've got one or two that are now you
know getting ready for some trials
okay going into the proceeding so we'll
see you guys it's been amazing and i'm
glad that you got a smile on your face
no no no well it's nice to be out
coaching you know right yeah
how did you find luck now i live in the
north so
a bit more in the countryside so a bit
more space to get out
because i know in london especially was
difficult huh
i'm from london originally so i know
that was more complicated for everybody
here
and of course we didn't have any
football so that was hard for all of us
huh
very very difficult we had no games
between
last november and this september we were
10 months without a game
so that that's tough when you're trying
to work with a team you know
england's absolutely about rashford and
sanctuary there's anything they share
like in the way they condone yourself
without achieving
every professional player has had lots
of setbacks
so when i was 14 i was released as a kid
i was at southampton trained at
southampton
and they said i wasn't going to be big
enough because i was quite skinny then
but really they didn't think i was going
to be good enough
and if you spoke to nearly every player
and
i guess lots of you or you've all
experienced this as well
at some point they've been knocked back
they've been rejected they've had maybe
an injury that kept them out
at an important time maybe you had a
coach that didn't believe in you
what you've always got to remind
yourself is that's just one person's
opinion
at one moment in time you know keep the
belief
that to do what you're doing now and
working with
really good coach with good players is a
is a really good way to get back into
the game
don't let anybody tell you you can't get
there
because i've seen so many people who
have got there who've been rejected
if you look in the england team now
tyrone wings was released
three or four times vardy went to
non-league went to fleetwood came back
to leicester
the biggest quality to answer your
question is
resilience yeah and resilience comes
from actually having setbacks and
and going you know what got to go again
i felt motivated to be honest i know
that the top coach is saying that i know
anything's possible really because
he's been through a lot he's seen a lot
of players who've been released
they've they've made it through to the
top so as he said it
never give up to have someone like him
to come in and tell us you know i mean
you've got to keep going you've got to
keep striving you have to you know you
have to
learn learn from the past and then just
keep going keep building from where you
are
to where you want to be it's incredible
it was great to be out coaching
and there's some super players and you
can see that
there's a lot of talent within the group
they've got a fantastic coach working
with them
so they're in a good they're in good
hands and
what i said to them at the end is that
every player
at some point in their career has had
rejection you know these guys have
obviously been through that
um but they've got opportunity now to to
become a better player
and whatever they do in their life the
experiences within football will help
them
amazing experience honestly you know
gareth southgate like i said to the boys
cream of the crop you know
england manager what i aspire to be as a
coach you know
working with a national team working
with the pro players seeing him do a
live session with my boys
and complimenting their quality and then
seeing him and his you know coaching
points etc
i learned a lot hopefully they learned a
lot what a guy to
take my job for the day it was superb so
um thank you very much sport bible
gary southgate gaffin maze rise on board
as we're out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a this is like a personal
accolade in respect of my
arsenal career which is i'd say yeah the
greatest day of my life this one was
when i broke the record when i went to
arsenal there were champions the last
two times that last three years so
there's a dressing room of champions i
went into and i just wanted to go there
and prove that i was good enough
belief belief